mental health issues it's really weird
they have alcoholism if alcohol isn't
introduced into their environments
but other than that when they don't have
that like happy people life in the taiga
did you ever see that
documentary no it's a werner herzog's
documentary on these people that live in
siberia
and all these guys do is live off the
land all they do is hunt and fish
and st and trap and you know they're
trapping furs
and that's how they buy like snowmobiles
and you know
hatchets and [ __ ] like that but the
majority of their time
is just shooting animals eating them
fishing and everybody's happy as
[ __ ] there's a whole village of people
that are so happy
they're just smiling and laughing
there's like no disputes everybody's
working together to try to get meat
you know they're showing how to like
like the craftsmanship involved in
making these snowshoes and sleds
they make their own skis i mean it's
really really
interesting because in the absence of
that
real day-to-day struggle that these
people
have we're almost like we're like
waiting for something to come along and
kick us in the ass
it's almost like we only react by nature
instead of act in some ways
well you know i'm actually fascinated by
that stuff too joe i i'm fascinated by
tribal cultures
yeah and uh but you know
there's no going back to that no no no
at some point there was an invention
happen and the invention was
the individual and once that was
invented i think the ancient greeks
invented it somewhere around
you know the time of socrates before
that
and at that point we no longer had
the tribe you know we no longer had that
wonderful uh thing enveloping us right
but
but the other you know if you also if
you look about look at afghanistan you
know which is a great place for us to
to study because we see it in the news
and we've had seen it which is like
in pashtunistan you get kind of pretty
much
tribal culture the way it was way way
way back when and i'm also
like when i was talking about reading
about the comanches a little while ago
the other thing one of the things about
tribes is they are unbelievably
cruel to whoever if they capture
anybody else or if there's anyone who
violates the tribe
uh you know it's not such an idyllic
world when you get into that side
wait a minute you mean it's not like
avatar yeah that was the side they left
out of
course but it's almost like that's uh
it's almost a cheat code to happiness
you know that kind of simple life where
you're doing you're constantly out there
doing
this world where it's it's just we don't
know what the hell to do and we don't
have action
as this kind of through line in our life
of okay gotta go
achieve that next goal which is me that
next goal which is fish that next goal
which is shelter
it's just this amorphous world and we
gotta figure it out
and i think one of the things you said
is is really important is
you got to just do the work and then but
at the start it's always a leap of faith
whatever that is like you don't know
exactly how it's going to turn out
but you know you take that first that
first step
you know and then just trust that if you
stay and you show up and you do that
every time
you know then some momentum's gonna
start going it's
you know it's just kind of a cliche it's
that old maslow pyramid you know
of where the the basic needs of hunger
or
you know clothing data and then when you
get to the top which is where we are
the needs become you know because we
have grocery stores you know there's no
bombs going off in the street
so now it becomes self-actualization or
asking the questions you know who am i
why am i here
all those tough questions right that
that the tribesmen don't have to ask
because they're too busy
right and to me this is where something
like martial arts or any kind of a
discipline or
art period the production of art this
podcast your
comedy whatever it is is
and i don't i can't really put my finger
on why but
i think it's an it's an answer
to this thing of being alone
being an individual being unfettered
from the tribal structure or from any
structure
where we're kind of floating in space
you know like uh
george clooney and uh you know trying to
figure out
who you know who am i why am i here
what do i want tough tough questions
you know